hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve swim in Rising water this is
a graph problem we're given an N byn
grid so it's going to be a square grid
each position in the grid represents the
elevation at that point and so basically
some amount of rain is falling at time T
the depth of the water everywhere is
going to be T but you're going to find
that we actually don't need to worry
about this T variable we don't really
need to worry about the water itself
because we are allowed to swim at any
position so from one square to another
square if and only if the elevation of
both the squares is less than or equal
to t t is the amount of time that's
passed and like I said we're actually
not going to have to keep track of what
T is the reason being let's keep reading
the problem we can swim an infinite
distance in zero time so you know if
let's say this was our our 2D grid right
1111 uh we could swim this entire
distance in zero time and the question
they're asking is if we start at the top
left of the grid and we go to the bottom
right of the grid What is the least time
it takes for us to reach the bottom
right Square so clearly we want to know
the time but why did I say we don't
actually have to keep track of this time
because think about it initially we're
going to be at time zero so let's say
the top left of our grid is zero then
let's say the right and bottom are are
two right and then maybe the bottom
right is also two so this is our grid
right we're starting here we want to get
to the bottom right so both of the paths
are pretty much the same to get there so
my question to you is what is going to
be the time it takes for us to get here
well remember initially there's zero
water and for us to be able to reach
this position too we can only reach it
if T is less than or equal to 2 because
that's the maximum elevation that we've
gone at so really what the question is
asking is what's going to be the path
from the top left to the bottom right
such that the the maximum height along
this path is minimized right because the
bottleneck is going to be whatever the
maximum height is because if the maximum
height is let's say uh four then no
matter what we do we're going to have to
wait for time to be less than or equal
to four so the question is what path can
we take to minimize what the t is and
then return that particular T value so
in this first example this is what the
grid actually looks like and you can see
we have two paths right we can go like
this bottom right and what's going to be
the max elevation we reach along this
path it's going to be three right so
that therefore the time we return has to
be three or uh if we go along this path
same thing right even though this is a
two so so for us to reach this position
to reach this two we would have to wait
for time to be less than or equal to two
but to reach this third position no
matter what we're going to have to wait
for time to equal three now of course
one idea you might have is just consider
every single possible path and then take
along each path what is the maximum
height and then return the minimum of
the maximum height from all those paths
right and if we're going to be going
through every single path it's going to
be exponential but there's actually a
trick a greedy way we can solve this
problem and you might remember a greedy
algorithm called jigra algorithm and we
can do a modified version of this
algorithm which will give us a Time
complexity of n^2 * log n so let me show
you that solution right now so like I
said we're going to be doing a modified
version of jra's algorithm it's pretty
much exactly like this algorithm just a
slight difference and you might know
that this algorithm requires a minimum
Heap now this it's a breath first search
jer's algorithm is basically a BFS
search a breath first search but instead
of doing a regular Q we're going to be
using a priority CU AKA a heap so we're
going to use a minimum Heap which is
going to contain the frontier of where
we're at so consider we start at the top
left what's our Frontier going to be
it's going to be the adjacent positions
right this position and the bottom
position which are going to be in our
Frontier so we're going to take both of
those and add them to our front here so
we're really going to add the
coordinates of these positions so think
of the columns as being 012 and the rows
also being 012 remember this is our
Target position we want to know from
here what's going to be the path that we
can take that's going to get us here
such that the maximum height along this
path is minimized so why am I using a
Min Heap why am I using Jar's algorithm
because remember we're being greedy what
did I just say we want to minimize the
maximum height along the path that takes
us to the result so if we start here at
zero which one of these paths am I going
to choose first would I choose the
height of two or would I choose the
height of one well of course we'd want
the minimum height right because it's
possible with a height of one we could
also find another path that will take us
to the result where the max height will
still remain as being one right whereas
if we go down this path we're basically
guaranteeing okay the maximum height
along the path to the the result is
going to be at minimum two so of course
we want to try the Min path first we
want to try the smaller height first so
when we take a position like this and
add it to our Min Heap we're going to
add three values the first one is going
to be the key for our minimum Heap which
is going to be the height so in this
position the height is one so that's
what we're going to add as the main key
for this Min Heap right so when we pop a
value from this Min Heap we want to pop
the one that had a minimum height
the other two values of course we're
going to be adding are the row and
column which are basically the
coordinates of this position and I'm
probably not going to write them out
each time just to keep this code a
little bit cleaner so that's kind of the
main idea and each time we're going to
be popping the minimum from our Min Heap
uh you know and then continuing on the
frontier so you know if we pop this
value then we're going to look at its
neighbors bottom and right the other two
neighbors are out of bounds or which
have already been visited we don't want
to visit the same uh position twice so
we're going to have a visit hash set for
that but I'm not going to draw that just
to keep things a little bit more simple
and suppose we take two pths you know
bottom right and we get to this two
position and we take another path you
know top right and then go down and get
to this position this one position right
and remember our goal is to find uh to
get to this this end point right so from
these two which of these two would I say
is going going to be the path that leads
to the result of course I would want to
favor this one by looking at it right
because okay the height over here is one
the height over here is two so that must
mean that this path is going to be the
path with a smaller Max height but
that's not actually true take a look at
this path there's a three along this
path whereas the maximum height along
this path uh was a two right this two or
this two so of course I would actually
want this path to be the one that leads
us to the result because the max height
along that that path is a two so how can
I do that this is where we modify jra's
algorithm we don't really care about the
edge weights in this algorithm we're not
finding the shortest path we're finding
the path with the smallest Max height so
when I get to this position when I get
here what I'm actually going to say is
the value I'm going to put here when I
add this to the Min Heap it's not going
to be a one with the row and column I'm
actually going to add a three because
I'm saying to get to this position in
the first place it took us a Max height
of three so it's it's a bit disingenuous
to say that this path only took a Max
height of one so I'm not going to add a
one in this position I'm going to add a
three so each time we add a coordinate
to the Min heat we want the maximum of
its own height and the height that came
before it so with that being said let's
go through a really quick dry run so
initially we have zero uh our Min Heap
let's pop it and then let's get its
neighbor so we have a two below it and
we have a one to the right so let's add
those so we add one row column and we
add two row column so excuse me if this
drawing gets a little bit messy but so
now once again we're going to pop from
the Min heat we're going to pop this one
because it has a smaller Max height so
we're going to uh pop it we're going to
add its two neighbors right uh right and
bottom and those two neighbors have a
height of three and four respectively
right so those are the max Heights along
each of those paths so we add those four
and that three to our Min Heap and now
we're going to pop again from the Min
Heap this time we're going to pop this
two uh because that's the minimum height
right now so we're going to pop this to
we're going to look at the bottom and
the right now the right has already been
visited but the bottom has not been
added to the Min Heap yet so let's add
that to the Min Heap it has a height of
one and you know we'll add those
coordinates but I'm just writing row
column just because to keep it a little
bit cleaner but actually hold on a
second I added a one here was that the
correct thing to do because the the
position that came before it was a two
it's disingenuous to say that this to
reach this position only takes a height
of one when in reality what came before
it was a two so what we're adding what
we're really adding to it is the maximum
of itself which is one and the one that
came before it which is two so the max
of one and two is obviously going to
evaluate to two so we're going to add
two and the row column to the Heap now
we're going to pop again from the
minimum Heap and this is going to be the
one that we pop so we'll add its
neighbors it doesn't have a bottom
neighbor it doesn't have a left neighbor
the above neighbor has already been
visited the right neighbor hasn't been
visited so let's add that to the m Heap
so again we'll take the maximum of
itself and what came before it so
basically the max of two and two so two
is going to be what we add and of course
its coordinates once again we're going
to pop from the in Heap pop the same one
this two We'll add its neighbors uh it
only has one neighbor this height of one
but that's actually going to be a two
because we know that you know the
maximum height along this path itself
was two so we're going to add a two row
column now once again one last time
we're going to pop from the Min Heap
we're going to pop this value we pop it
and before we continue we're going to
see that okay it's its coordinates are
the destination coordinates so we can
return now what are we going to return
well what was the max height along this
path what was the max height along this
path that uh we had to do obviously a
two in either of these positions but are
we actually going to have to look
through the entire path again no because
when we added this to the Min Heap we
added it as a two and then we added its
coordinates so we can say that the max
height to reach it was a two this is the
value that we're going to return and
then we're done so that's kind of the
general picture of how this algorithm is
going to work coding it up is not too
bad if you know Jar's Alm and you know
how to use a minimum Heap so now let's
dive into that code so the first thing
I'm going to do is get the length of the
grid we know it's a square grid so we
can just uh say that n is both of the
dimensions we are going to have a visit
hash set to make sure we don't visit the
same coordinate twice so let's do that
we're also going to have a minimum Heap
remember we're going to initialize the
minimum Heap with values the first value
is going to be the time that's going to
be the key that's going to determine
what we actually pop from them in Heap
and then we're going to add the
coordinates the time is basically also
the max height so you can call it time
or the you know Max height that it'll
take and initially we're going to add
the top left coordinate so what are the
what's the height of the top left
coordinate it's going to be whatever is
in that position in the grid and the
coordinates themselves are going to be 0
0 that's the top left and since we're
adding this to the Min Heap we can go
ahead and actually add to visit uh the
position 0 0 cuz we don't want to have
to visit that again and last but not
least we're going to need a little
helper variable for us directions which
are going to tell us the four directions
that we can travel in 01 uh you'll see
where we're going to be using these in
just a moment it'll make the code a
little bit cleaner for us mainly that's
why I'm doing it so these are the four
directions we can travel in that's going
to be useful for us when we're doing our
BFS solution so while our Min Heap is
nonempty that's when we're going to be
popping just like I showed in the
drawing explanation so we can say in
Python at least the way we can pop from
A Min Heap is going to be Heap q. Heap
pop and we're going to get three
variables right the time or the max
height it took us uh and the row column
so those are going to be the three
things that we pop now if we're also
going to take this and add it to visit
uh because this previously was not
visited so we can say that this
coordinate has now been visited now if
this is the destination so if row is n
minus one and
column is n minus one that means we've
reached the destination so what we're
going to return is whatever the time or
the max height it took us to get to this
position but if we're not returning it
that's when we're going to actually
start traversing the four neighbors so
we're going to use the difference in R
the difference in column the basically
the directions in our directions
variable that we defined and using those
we're going to compute the neighbor row
and the neighbor column we can say the
neighbor row is just going to be R plus
Dr neighbor column is just going to be
the column plus the difference in the
column now it's possible that these
could be out of bounds or this
coordinate has already been visited so
let's check that so if neighbor row is
less than zero or neighbor column is
less than zero or neighbor row is equal
to n meaning it's out of bounds or
neighbor column is equal to n meaning
it's also out of bounds or this position
has already been visited so we can check
that like this so neighbor row neighbor
column in visit so if any of these
evaluate to true then we're going to
skip this position basically we're going
to continue to the next iteration of the
loop but if none of these do evaluate
then we want to mark this position as
visit because we're about to add it to
our Min Heap so let's first add U Market
as visit and actually I just noticed if
we're going to be marking it as visit uh
right as we add it to the Min Heap
there's no need to Mark something as
visited after it's been popped from the
Min Heap so I'm going to delete that
line of above and so we're going to mark
this as visit and then we're going to go
ahead and add it to our our Min um Heap
so we're going to say Heap q. Heap push
to the Min Heap this uh coordinate so
what are we adding as the coordinate so
of course we're going to add the
neighbor row and the neighbor column but
remember what's the first variable we're
adding we're adding the max height that
it took so we're either going to say the
maximum of itself or or rather it's its
uh previous position so maximum of T and
the maximum of whatever the height is at
this particular position so the height
at neighbor row neighbor column so this
will make sure that the value that we
add here is always going to be the max
height along the path that it took for
us to reach this neighbor row and
neighbor column position and believe it
or not that is the entire code we don't
have to put a return statement on the
outside because it's guaranteed that we
can reach the target position and once
we do we're automatically going to
return whatever the max height was to
reach that Target position so this is
the entire code you can see that it is
very efficient it's a very efficient
solution so I hope this was helpful if
it was please like And subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and I'll
hopefully see you pretty soon thanks for
watching